c'est avec le chant des oiseaux que yam
et regina entament leur journée de
travail
premier arrêt l'entrepôt pour récupérer
les remords trouve une fois accroché au
vélo une remorque peut contenir jusqu'à
300 livres de matériel
il y met des outils et pierre d'ardoisé
tout pour concevoir des plates-bandes
on va petites entreprises locales les
jardiniers à bicyclette existe depuis 13
ans ils font tous aller le une fois les
outils de base à bord deuxième arrêt
centre de location d'outils c'est un
immense escabeau de 16 pieds que yann
trimballera dans les rues de montréal
tout est bien en selle
[Musique]
troisième arrêt outremont on est proche
une grosse compagnie paysagement on est
quelques employés on a vraiment un lien
direct avec les clients
souvent on devient même ami avec eux
puis on fait affaire avec des pépinières
sur l'île de montréal pour comme nos
fournisseurs pour venir livrer si une
grosse cargaison de terre l'opération
sera importante aujourd'hui les
jardiniers vont défricher tout le
parterre nous n'en ferons tout ce qu'on
fait c'est à broc avec avec la force de
notre gîte bureau puis on n'utilise pas
d'outil à gaz jean alemany donc ici
électriques pour faire place au soleil
dans ce jardin l'entreprise éco
responsable oeuvre principalement dans
les quartiers centraux de montréal ainsi
qu'à longueuil c'est juste que je peux
pas le faire
maria a fait appel à eux pour l'aider
mais surtout en raison des valeurs de
l'entreprise qu'il fait très bien ces
travailleurs donc c'est possiblement un
peu plus cher mais je crois que il
respecte ces travailleurs camille
respecte l'environnement
notre entreprise à des prix semblables à
des gosses entreprises aussi et ce qui
est intéressant on en croit les humains
les jardiniers par exemple pendant une
journée il y aura cinq jalinier mais
avec un gros company is peut-être juste
une machine lacunes travailleurs
donc c'est 5 janvier qui gagnent de
l'argent des jardiniers qui sont aussi
des conseillers au même moment a
heureusement centre reçoit des services
personnalisés j'avais envie de me sentir
en italie dans mon jardin
habib football voyager elle fera
elle-même son jardin même place les
plantes bien monté un peu roulé mais
depuis à m'expliquer appelé les
différents niveaux
la raison et tout ça pour ça c'est moi
qui va exécuter
à autrement sur le terrain de marjah le
travail est loin d'être terminé par un
essai de planté les plantes indigènes
des plantes comestibles qu'il les prend
qui ont une utilité
[Musique]
trois jours plus tard après le travail
de cinq jardiniers et 0 gaz à effet de
serre le jardin de marjah est devenu
réalité
un des projets les plus ambitieux de la
petite compagnie dont yann est très fier
ici marie josée paquet comme radio
canada montréal